[Music]
hey folks I'm ace I'm Jed and today
we're going to be talking about how to
do intelligent Gmail processing using
cloud functions so first a quick
background on what we're doing today and
how our application works so you
probably know about the various G suite
Web Apps everything from Gmail to
calendar to slides to Docs to sheets on
and so forth but what you may not know
about is the API is behind these apps
that effectively provide a scalable and
programmatic access to the G suite data
underlying these applications now of
course in terms of what we can do with
these API is especially when we combine
them with Google Cloud the sky really is
the limit here just to pick on a couple
use cases in particular we could say
maybe we want to categorize images in
our Gmail messages using the cloud
vision API maybe we want to export Dana
regenerate in G CPSA in a bigquery job
or something to Google sheets maybe we
want to even find sensitive data using
the data loss prevention API that we
have in our Google Drive accounts so
today we're going to focus particularly
on that first use case so when it comes
to Gmail processing what we're gonna try
and do is say we want to take all of our
incoming images or excuse me incoming
messages and anything that has an image
on it we want to find that image extract
that image classify it using the cloud
vision API and export those classifiers
- excuse me - Google sheets right so
that's what we're going to do today and
what we can do with this extension the
sort of so what if you will is that we
can use this to easily search for images
in our inbox so in terms of the products
and services that we're going to use
today obviously we're going to be using
Gmail and Gmail has this really cool
feature called the watch API right now
what the law the watch API lets you do
is send notifications to a cloud pub/sub
topic whenever you receive an incoming
email right so cloud pub/sub provides a
simple scalable message queues which we
can then use to trigger cloud functions
which will host our event processing
code so in turn cloud functions then
contacts cloud vision and says hey I
have an image right I want you to tell
me what kinds of categories apply to
this image so
maybe let's say it's an image of blue
sky right so cloud vision is gonna say
okay well maybe it's blue maybe it has
the sky and it maybe it has to do with
nature right then cloud functions is
gonna take those categories export them
to a Google sheet using the sheets API
so now I'm gonna hand it over to Chen
who's gonna talk about how we built this
application hi
so this this project is actually a
simple five-step process first you set
up Gmail push notifications so that
every time a new message arrives at
their Gmail inbox Gmail will send a push
notification to call it pops up called
pops abuddin delivered is push
notification to call functions an over
function will query the Gmail API and
download the full message if there is an
image attachment called functions will
send the image data to call vision API
for analysis and call function will then
write an analysis to a Google sheet now
imagine that I send myself a picture of
blue sky Gmail will send a push
notification upon arrival of this
message and the teach notification will
be delivered via called pops up to the
call functions since there is an image
attachment called functions we'll send
the image data to called vision API for
analysis this is a picture of blue sky
so essays have just mentioned College
and API will probably return results
like blue sky in nature etc and called
function will write the result to a
Google sheet now we would not love to
talk more about the Gmail called vision
API etc but before that we really want
to mention that accessing GSB data
requires explicit approval from
end-users 3-speed api's along with other
Google APs are protected by the industry
standard open house to work workflow
normally you have to perform this
workflow manually to get access but here
we use this really convenient note yes
and I believe you'd buy the team to help
us automate the process here's the code
for handling the open house workflow as
you can see it's really this package how
provides us to really convenient
functions also you need and I'll call
back the also you need function as its
name implies it helps initiate our open
house to work flow and the callback
function processes authorization data
returned from Google servers and save it
in your persistent storage for future
reference
here's the code for downloading the
Gmail message as you can see the code is
pretty straightforward you just acquire
with the Gmail API for the most recent
messages Gmail API will return you a
number of message IDs and you can use
those IDs to download the full message
here's the code for analyzing data using
call vision API you basically just send
the image data to call vision API and
called vision API or return you a number
of labels the categories of the image me
here we take the top three labels and
rather write them to a Google sheet the
code once again is pretty
straightforward if it's only just called
Google see the API how the idea that I
have a new row of data I need to append
to the sheet and the Google sheet ABA
will perform the operation automatically
for you behind the scenes now I'll hand
it back to H talk about running and
deploying this demo so you'd think given
how many different possibilities are
exposed by this combination of cloud and
G suite that deploying this would
actually be a lot of effort right
surprisingly it's not you can generally
break it down into these three simple
steps so first of all you're going to
want to enable these various api's that
we have listed to the left here then
you're going to want to download the
code by cloning the github project now
the URL for this is github comm slash
Google code labs all one word slash GCF
- Gmail - code lab and unfortunately we
are having their couple technical issues
with our code labs but if and when those
are resolved you can also check this out
in the hands-on lab section as well now
last but not least you're going to want
to follow the instructions in that code
lab which will talk you through
deploying this code to GCP and now I'm
going to hand it back to Chen who's
going to take us through a demo
so we start this demo by calling the
asana function this function will help
us set up between male push
notifications and this function will
redirect us to the site if it's a Google
page where you can sign him as your own
Google account here you will see this at
this Abbot's and verified warning that's
because we are testing this local make
so it's actually safe to ignore this
morning and now Cooper will tell us that
this I requires the following permission
to continue basically need access to
your Gmail inbox so that it can set up
the Gmail push notification if you grant
the system the access you will see this
success message successfully set up
Gmail push notifications now ace will
send me an email with a picture
unfortunately we're having issues with
the internet here yeah we have pre fed
some of these images so you can see what
it looks like in the real world yes so
basically as you can see here's a
picture of a beautiful cat and the this
this image has been categorized about
the cultivation API here along with the
sender of the email and the name of the
attachment my Shaitan will still
probably will probably still take a few
seconds for the new message to arrive
it's being quite slow so unfortunately a
conference Wi-Fi hit-or-miss let me give
you that one more second it's having
issues we should probably just go on
yeah like legal difficulties everybody
did sorry about that
so that's it from us if you have any
questions please do let us know either
email us I am fast at Google calm with
fast with two ways you can also do me on
Twitter at server loss I'm changing
Mecca at Google calm thanks for your
time and we hope you enjoy the rest of
your time here at Google cloud next show
so much
[Applause]
[Music]